et l'hôpital charcot implantée à plaisir
va subir un vrai lifting construit au
début des années 60 les quatre pavillons
actuelle installés dans le centre
psychiatrique vont être totalement
réhabilité un bâtiment flambant neuf de
14 mille mètres carrés devraient sortir
de terre en mars 2018
le projet était attendue depuis plus de
dix ans par les patients on écoute tout
de suite le directeur du centre
hospitalier jacques peyrat il était au
micro ondes et mickaël mille euros c'est
un grand soulagement c'est un chantier
qui qui est très atypique du fait de
nombreuses défections technique et
erreurs techniques juridiques et c'est
assez exceptionnel en france d'ailleurs
mais c'est un grand soulagement
effectivement pour l'équipe de direction
et pour aussi les personnes de l'écu de
la direction espace technique qui
travaille depuis des mois et des mois
pour faire redémarrer le chantier et le
coût global de l'opération s'élèvera à
20 5 millions d'euros financés par
l'hôpital avec l'aide de l'agencé
régionale de santé
les travaux devraient débuter avant cet
été